um let's speak to
uh let's speak to evan from boston evan
you are on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
hey i'm actually um
a new new follower new listener so i
really appreciate the show
um and appreciate your views on things
thank you
and my question is you've talked about
this a little bit if you have uh friends
or family that
lean
lean republican
but
you know kind of bought into the trump
thing and are leaning away from it but
you know if he becomes the republican
nominee again
you know we'll probably
vote republican again um you know how do
you facilitate conversations maybe with
folks who
hopefully
aren't
my opinion right like not too far gone
right
maybe they are
you know i don't know because i don't
have any people like that in my family
now
my my girlfriend does have some people
in her family who are hard right
trumpists but they live in a different
part of the country and neither sheen or
i really have any contact with them i
mean we see what they're posting to
facebook but i don't i don't know what i
would say because i i just don't have
any people like that in my family
that's a
how does um here's a good question how
does your
how does your girlfriend feel about it
as she's the one with the uh the
familial ties if you know what i mean
yeah i mean she thinks that they're
wrong about everything and does not
engage in any political discussions with
them whatsoever
gotcha but still kind of does she
facilitate a
um a healthy relationship healthcare
relationship yeah she has very little
relationship with most of those people
gotcha yeah
yeah that's how
i mean just that's how i'm
slowly slowly going and my wife is
i guess in a similar position as you
where she has no relationship with these
folks at all and here's the thing i
don't think any one thing is the right
thing to do is that when peop i get this
question a lot
how should i maintain or not maintain or
how should i confront people
it's all about what kind of a
relationship you want to have some
people legitimately say i
value family no matter what they think
and i want to maintain a relationship so
we will agree either to disagree or to
not talk about politics or whatever i
mean i think my family in argentina is
an example of that where in argentina
all my family is basically on the left
but you have people who love christina
kirschner and that whole regime and
people who don't like it and
typically they just agree not to talk
about politics at family gatherings and
it sort of works okay
gotcha okay
so i guess the next step for me is to
figure out where and i guess it's where
i'm struggling personally where my
values lie like right am i going to be a
person who is like yeah family no matter
what or
when your family's pretty
a bunch of jerks maybe maybe not yeah
and i mean listen there's a difference
between
there's people who think there should be
a 10 flat tax on everything it's like
okay all right well that's i mean we can
disagree on that versus
i think the jews are the devil and are
going to hell that's going to be someone
very difficult to put differences aside
with you know
right right and i think i think at first
it was leaning towards the
first example right and then when trump
came out and
kind of made it more normal to be
a little bit more racist to be a little
bit more vocal about these views yeah i
started to see a different side of my
family as they saw that that that was
okay to say these things right yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and so now it's like
you know and then also as i'm growing
older 28
having been more developed cognitively
and being able to kind of like recognize
these things as you know when you're 12
14 15 not being able to recognize
these these types of things well let us
know how it works out
yeah thanks i appreciate the advice all
right there's evan from boston and that
is going to do it for us today we will
take more calls next week i look forward
to it
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video